hallo deutsch schule zusammengesetzten
omen fuß plus bei ist gleich der fußball
der fußball
ich spiele fußball
ich renne mit dem fußball über den
fußballplatz
fußballplatz lippen plus stift ist
gleich der lippenstift der lippenstift
der lippenstift ist ein stift für die
lippen
sie benutzt den roten lippenstift sie
benutzt den roten lippenstift liegen
plus schirm ist gleich der regenschirm
der regenschirm der regenschirm schützt
vor regen
der regenschirm schützt vor regen wenn
es regnet nehme ich meinen regen
schirm wenn es regnet nehme ich meinen
regenschirm hand plus tasche ist gleich
die handtasche die handtasche die
handtasche ist rot die handtasche ist
rot jede frau braucht mindestens eine
gute handtasche jede frau braucht
mindestens eine gute handtasche was ist
in deiner handtasche sonne plus brille
ist gleich die sonnenbrille die
sonnenbrille
ich trage eine sonnenbrille
wie findest du meine neue sonnenbrille
plus wer ist gleich der eisbär der
eisbär der eisbär lebt in der antarktis
der eisbär lebt in der antarktis
erdbeere plus torte ist gleich
die erdbeertorte die erdbeertorte heute
packe ich eine leckere erdbeertorte
heute packe ich eine leckere
erdbeertorte buch + regal ist gleich das
bücherregal das bücherregal das
bücherregal ist ein regal für bücher das
bücherregal ist ein regal für bücher was
ist dein lieblingsbuch hand plus ist
gleich der handschuh der handschuh
die winterhandschuhe die
winterhandschuhe
der putz handschuh der putz handschuh
der boxhandschuh der boxhandschuh der
baseball handschuh der baseball
handschuh beim skifahren trage ich sie
handschuhe beim skifahren trage ich sie
handschuhe beim boxen trage ich
boxhandschuhe beim boxen trage ich
boxhandschuhe beim putzen trage ich putz
handschuhe beim putzen trage ich putz
handschuhe plus würfel ist gleich die
eiswürfel die eiswürfel die cola mit
eiswürfeln die cola mit eiswürfeln soll
ich eine ice backe challenge machen soll
ich eine eisdecke challenge machen
ok jetzt wird's kalt okay jetzt wird's
kalt platz + ring ist gleich der ohrring
der
mohring die ohrringe die ohrringe
es gibt dinge in gold und silber
es gibt ohrringe in gold und silber was
findest du besser gold oder silber
spiegel plus ist gleich das spiegelei
das spiegelei das spiegelei in der
pfanne braten das spiegelei in der
pfanne braten zum frühstück esse ich ein
leckeres spiegelei zum frühstück esse
ich ein leckeres spiegelei polizei plus
auto ist gleich das polizeiauto das
polizeiauto das polizeiauto hat
blaulicht das polizeiauto hat blaulicht
die polizei fährt mit dem polizeiauto
die feuerwehr fährt mit dem
feuerwehrauto die feuerwehr fährt mit
dem feuerwehrauto hals
+ kette ist gleich die halskette die
halskette die frau trägt eine schöne
halskette eine halskette mit perlen ist
eine perlenkette eine halskette mit
perlen ist eine perlenkette apfel plus
baum ist gleich der apfelbaum der
apfelbaum die äpfel hängen an dem
apfelbaum yoga plus lehrer ist gleich
der yogalehrer der yogalehrer die
yogalehrerin die yogalehrerin ich lerne
yoga mit einem yoga lehrer
ich lerne yoga mit einem yoga lehrer
papier plus flugzeug ist gleich das
papier flugzeug das papier flugzeug
ich baue heute ein papier flugzeug im
büro
rock plus musik ist gleich die rockmusik
die rockmusik ich liebe rockmusik ich
liebe rockmusik die band macht richtig
coole rockmusik die band macht richtig
coole rockmusik salz plus wasser ist
gleich das salzwasser das salzwasser in
einem ozean ist das wasser salzig
deshalb sagt man salzwasser in einem
ozean ist das wasser salzig deshalb sagt
man salzwasser die salzwasser fische
leben im salzwasser die salzwasser
fische leben im salzwasser brief plus
tasche ist gleich die brieftasche die
brieftasche die brieftasche ist ein
altes deutsches wort für das
portemonnaie die brieftasche ist ein
portemonnaie
ursprünglich war es eine tasche für
briefe deshalb brieftasche ursprünglich
war es eine tasche für briefe des
brieftasche wo ist bloß meine
brieftasche geblieben wo ist bloß meine
brieftasche geblieben hund plus baby ist
gleich das hundebaby das hundebaby
hundebabys sind so süß hundebabys sind
so süß telefon + buch ist gleich das
telefonbuch das telefonbuch in einem
telefonbuch stehen viele telefonnummern
in einem telefonbuch stehen viele
telefonnummern in deutschland gibt es
denn jeder stadt ein offizielles
telefonbuch in deutschland gibt es in
jeder stadt ein offizielles telefonbuch
holz + tisch ist gleich der holztisch
der holztisch
der holztisch ist aus holz der holztisch
ist aus holz
ich arbeite an einem holztisch
ich arbeite an einem holztisch arbeitest
du auch an einem holztisch abonniere
jetzt den kanal der halle deutsch schule
und aktiviere das kleine glöckchen gib
uns jetzt einen daumen nach oben und
klicke auf diese playlist für weitere
videos zum deutsch lernen